venez vous l'avoir normand roy et
propriétaire du plus vieux commerce de
l'avenue du mont-royal 100 ans
d'existence
il a choisi récemment de mettre la clé
sous la porte faute de rentabilité et de
relève
je reçois beaucoup d'amour depuis un
mois les clients reviennent pense puis
les témoignages de satisfaction de
regrets pied qu'est ce qu'on va faire
vous serez plus leur plus haut le
commerce
bon je sais ce que je vaux nostalgique
le commerce d'abord ouvert par son
grand-père au 1 avenue du mont-royal
ouest en 1919 est à l'image de
nombreuses boutiques de montréal elle
façonne l'identité de la métropole les
concerts d'arrondissement responsable de
l'urbanisme à l'arrondissement du
plateau-mont-royal marie plourde
planchait déjà sur un projet de
protection des enseignes emblématiques
lorsqu'elle a appris la nouvelle j'avais
coopéré dans la demande y avait vraiment
une urgence et nous on avait quand même
fait un travail de fourmi à 20 mais on
n'était pas prêt à déposer un projet de
règlement alors c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a mis le pied sur
l'accélérateur puis on a présenté cet
avis de motion là avec les 66 adresse
qu'on retrouve sur le sommaire
décisionnel ainsi de théâtre montréalais
hachoir ou fameux big boss en passant
par des affiches plus ludiques comme
elvis ameublement ou même le cinéma de
l'amour l'arrondissement à geler
temporairement tout retrait possible
dancing d'ici à ce qu'un répertoire et
une réglementation officielle soit mis
en place
bien sûr à chaque fois je pensais au
coin de l'avenue papineau puis l'avenue
du mont-royal je vaux
naturellement tourné la tête à droite
puis a regardé si l'enceinte si elle est
encore là pendant cinq ans dans dix ans
je le fais ici julie marceau radio
canada montréal